I am so sorry I have to deliver this bad
news to you there's nothing else I can
do
are you are you hearing this you're just
not gonna say okay yeah no I can't deal
with this difficult meetings difficult
partners difficult emotions half of us
and b2 semi sexers will be graduating in
two weeks the other half you'll be out
of here in less than you can imagine and
out there in the real world as leaders
there will come a time and you will have
to deliver uncomfortable news
don't unhappy crowd breaking a
partnership in their startup letting go
of an employee quitting your first post
GSB job this news our height to deliver
so how do we go about it we've compiled
knowledge from some of Stanford's geez
beasts most popular classes and
professors including managing growing
enterprises and strategic communications
and other public sources like forts
business development council and
authorities in this topic to bring you
some clear steps that you can follow
when you have to deliver banners but
before you get it but before we get into
the steps let's take a look at what our
goal should be what your goal despite
regardless of the message regardless of
the news that you have to deliver what
should be your goal and it should be
twofold in one hand you must be clear
you want your message to come across
unambiguously on the other
you want to display empathy and
compassion yes the Librium hardness is
hard but receiving them is harder and
you cannot expect everyone to react
calmly after all only a handful of your
colleagues will have taken to Tripoli so
we propose we're here to give you four
steps to help you prepare for delivering
bad news managing your body language as
you do in ready to to react
confrontation if it arises and closing
effective communication begins before
blunder how many of you have to deliver
bad news before how many of you think
you got it well one person it's hard
it's it's very difficult so we put
together a couple of tips for you to
deliver the message as effectively as
you can number one put yourself in the
shoes of your audience think about how
each member of your audience will
perceive your message what are the most
pressing questions that will come in
their mind use the answers to these as
the ODE of your message roleplay we've
done a lot of this at the GSB but it
cannot be emphasized enough practice
your speech till you can deliver it
calmly and confidently take a friend
role play the Q&A with them in fact we
would even say that think of the two
worst case an audio as possible practice
those out as well one worst case
scenario could be someone threatening to
sue you it's possible number three what
prepared use first don't beat around the
bush we have a tendency as human beings
to sugarcoat bad news we time fit it in
between seemingly better pieces of news
don't do that this is what you are all
paid the big bucks for be bold put it in
the first 60 seconds of your
conversation this gives your audience a
time for the lines of message and also
gives you the time to see their
reactions to the same another thing you
can do is be mindful of your choice
when you the same message deliver to a
standing crowd in the middle of your
office will be interpreted very
differently from the campfire at an
off-site think about your venue and use
it to your advantage let's do a little
activity don't you have to close your
eyes and bring yourselves back to the
most stressful meeting you have ever
been a part of you're feeling pressure
anxiety nervousness beyond your control
the heart is beating fast your muscles
are tense your palms are sweaty you
don't know what to do you're dreading
what's happening next and open your eyes
and be conscious of your body like most
of you have crunched up I saw a few
eyebrows furring and some like starting
to nervously shake and that's what I
want you guys to remember is that even
when you don't intend to your body will
show your emotions and in a crisis
situation your body language matters
your audience will be looking to you for
cues think of kids in a playground when
a child Falls what's the first thing
they do they look behind and their
parents to see their reaction if the
parent is freaking out their kids will
inevitably start to scream but if
they're calm then the child will simply
pick themselves up and go back to play
just like children your audience will be
looking to you for cues on how to act
and to assess the severity of the
situation your body language must
therefore exude colonists control and
grounding first make sure that you
position yourself at the center of the
room
or the table this exudes control and
leadership ii maintain calm but firm
demeanor throughout you the neutral with
empathetic expression
sit up straight torso toward your
audience and make good eye contact do
not I repeat do not look down because
that will show that you're not equipped
for the situation and finally make sure
your audience feels hurt if you do not
you're risking alienating losing and
even angering your audience members that
if they feel disrespected or ignored so
what you can do is lean in tilt your
head slightly and when someone is
talking to you make sure you nod your
head to acknowledge what they're saying
okay so you're prepared their body
language is on point but you can't quite
control how the other person is going to
react let's see what could happen how
many times we've had this what just
happened
you've just been confronted in a meeting
it got emotional it got personal raise
your hand if you've been in this
situation before what did it feel like
Jason wanted to feel it flooded what
else feelings in the moment what's that
possible right maybe your heart was
racing your palms got sweaty you felt
kind of fight or flight situation you
want to fight back you want to fight
fire with fire let's think through
though in this tough situation what's
the right way to really handle it first
take a deep breath stay calm
assess the situation objectively and
remember remind yourself there is no
lion in the wing with you even though
you might feel like there is by staying
calm you'll be able to take stock of the
situation and do so calmly second think
about the optimal outcome for the whole
team objectively not just in the moment
thinking about the optimal outcome for
you in a one-on-one battle with this
other person three now it's time to
actually act
what's the mantra here
defuse defuse defuse your gut instinct
is going to be to fight fire with fire
but what happens when we fight fire with
fire
what do you get just a bigger fire that
doesn't help anyone you want to calm the
situation and by calming tensions
that'll make it that much harder for the
other person to stay angry at you
finally try to separate the issue from
your from the person identify what the
real issue is why is this person
actually angry could it be about the
layoffs from last week or is it possible
that their boss has been taking credit
for all their work if you identified the
real issue that's driving their anger
and you separate the issue from the
person it'll allow you and the team to
be that much likelier to come out of the
situation a winner so we talked about
bidding before the meeting we talked
about body language and we talked about
how to confront how to handle the calm
lardons in the room but how about we end
the meetings when emotions are on the
fire when everyone is very emotional
it's hard to get good outcomes it's hard
to be hired but how you're enter
meetings would make a huge difference so
here are four tips from my side first
set a timer I know this is very very
simple but very very effective once
everyone in the meeting have a sense of
limited time they tends to focus on what
is important second repeat repeat the
key message I was hard to deliver the
bad news even first time in delivering
second time isn't more hard I couldn't
tell you were here no one it was so hard
when I was role playing but it's so much
worth taking that pain because once
everyone leave that room people are
often confused how many of you were in
your experience
leave the meeting and felt that I'm not
sure why I was even invited I'm not sure
what the message of the meeting I can
feel like lot of us in the room had that
experience so repeating the message even
though it's very painful is the key
third offer next steps I found this
quote very very interesting when Rome
was burning people still wanted to know
what the future of the city would look
like people are always furious it's
important to tell them what's next what
they can expect from you and what's my
expected from them and keeping that and
laying out those next steps make
everyone align for follow-up when
there's a heat in the room and when
there's a lot of arguments it's good to
follow up with the people and catch up
how they are doing once there is some
time gap between that meeting and once
you follow up you blog or comma and they
will hear you more it will also set up a
good energy when your next meeting
so the fallout is crucial so we talked
foreign language preparation and their
confrontation and close at this point
would love for you to engage with us
either with questions or comments if you
have any experiences dealing with this
but also we would also love to hear your
voice now